oh [__] it's the Lord's Day
[__] you thought I forgot about
your never ever you're the reason will
you [__] keep me picking you
understand me between you're my little
daughter it's the reason why I [__]
get up every morning I'm ready for you
[__] I know you're watching
football you're jumping up and down
you're about to go to a barbecue a kids
party who gives a [__] this is the most
important part of your day is getting
your head together greetings from so by
October you know I'm saying it's still
alive and [__] kicking I'm just doing
it my way like Sinatra
what are you [__] nuts or what Sunday
the 21st of October slinging dick and
giving out toothpicks uncle Joey 55 one
foot in the grave when I had a peeling I
don't give a [__]
look at this [__] monstrosity here
it's so bad told by how to break it how
just to let you [__] there's no I
ain't [__] around today I hope you're
doing well I hope your families would
want to hope you're healthy and I hope
you're [__] happy because that's the
most important thing you have 10 mil in
the bank but if you're not happy who
give us a Frenchman's [__] I'm showing
up with nothing but gifts like the
[__] three polarize did when Jesus
was born bootylicious at 21 percent a
little big smooth little 20 [__] 2%
and then we got Bubble [__] whatever
the bubble OG this [__] will [__]
kill you it's at 26% go over there it's
[__] the little Zeki brands today you
go to urban trees today or yesterday
that thing today yeah whatever the [__]
just telling my Sencha if you bring in
some coupon they give you whatever gram
for a [__] dollar five dollars but
you gotta go to urban trees on Ventura
right there totally care you well anyway
enough with that [__] it's about me and
you and what the [__] we're doing this
week for starters let's fill up a bowl
cuz why [__] convergently a sci-fi
guys drink coffee in the car suck my
dick how about a smoke brief right apart
that's what I want to [__] do you
know I'm saying once this [__] drink
coffee in the car like a [__] mama
local yay me
[__] that [__] I want to be outside
absorbing the vitamin D look at me I'm
looking like [__] Sinatra when he was
[__] 22 anyway smoking [__]
oh the savage what his back look at him
he's got yellow teeth he's got one eye
he looks like a rose Amber's [__] but
[__] it it happens sometimes you got to
do what the [__] you got to do I love
you [__]
you understand me this Thursday night I
show up and [__] Cleveland with my
man George Perez we got [__] four
show five shows and Saturdays already
sold out this Late Show so whatever the
[__] you're thinking you better get on
it I'll be it's Lyman's Fryman x'
whatever the [__] it is friday for a
nice pastrami sandwich [__] Weight
Watchers I'm gonna blow [__] on a
tremendous load when I'm there I love my
little pastrami I'm like the Cuban Jew
when it comes to pastrami nice bread and
slime ins that nobody makes it better
than them I think it's Lyman's fine I
don't [__] know I'm not good with
names I'm good with reefer and [__]
and telling people to go suck my dick
anyway Joey what's with the [__] hair
beat and we're gonna [__] do some
good food so what we're doing some food
to Lutz listen who gives a [__] about
last week it's this week that matters
the Dodgers won last night they know
well and simple they gotta go on the
Fenway Park now and try to deter on
those [__] you understand me so
whatever happened last week happen last
week to learn from that [__] nothing you
could do about it in the past it's this
week you're gonna go out with a big dick
and a [__] long Jack go and tell
everybody the suckit pick where they
like it or not you got to impose your
will you gotta let these [__]
know you're not [__] around
understand me I'm up early every morning
doing what I gotta do you think I want
to do it [__] them I rather sit at
home and watch TV and smoke reefer like
some [__] sack of [__] but 55 I gotta
hustle every damn hustling more now than
when I was a [__] burglar I'm
hustling more now than when I was a
burden that was a burglar and hustle
this [__] art anyway well Joey what's
with the [__] beat let's park let's
pull a little [__] bass moved in here
a little big small
bootylicious combination for my people
over there I don't know what the [__]
made this but this is [__] delicious
just disagree for listen California
strong some [__] heat I know whatever
I know listen you know me I only hang
out with people that are missing an
eyeball
I want to see a [__] battle woman
smoking weed just cuz you show up with a
tattoo and a picture for 20 you just
suck my dick and call me shorty you
understand me I deal with professional
zone that's why you say buddy else
hanging out here [__] no you know why
cuz they know they'll leave here when I
[__] twist I'm saying it's a good for
you if you're not focus when you suck
dick gonna fly goes by your mother house
stay like that for the rest of your life
Biko we've got your well we'll see the
Sun see me Mitchell I think I don't
really a liar a little [__] less man
yo fee on a Sunday morning but Joey
you're gonna Sparkle Wallace be sparking
oh just tremendous she understand me I
went to to strength and conditioning
classes last week I went to two
kickboxing Zoran jujitsu I'm holding up
to my end of the bargain a [__] saw
pocket all but made no [__] sweets
I waited today I [__] Weight Watchers
I'm a little on the heavy side but not
really not really because I'm throwing
weight so I'm gonna cut them building
muscle but losing effect you know I'm
saying I'm throwing you off and it's
easier to [__] gain muscle than it is
to lose [__] fat so do the math ain't
no [__] dietitian I'm just telling
you what the man told me okay but
besides that let's keep smoking what if
the [__] here beat about diets who
gives a [__] Joey it's my cheat day
I mean pretzels until [__] sock comes
out of my [__]
oh yeah oh yeah that's the one that made
Anthony Bourdain hang himself
that's some [__] kicker this is the
[__] right here this is the [__]
you feel your [__] lungs percolating
you start hearing sirens in this [__]
but I don't give a [__] I'm used to it
40 years I've been marked and lurking
around in the deep waters of the
underworld you think a little reef is
gonna stop you no oh my got it I have to
Micro tell us because of that one you
know what and what are you what are you
bothering me for with these [__]
details
it's Sunday mother [__] the Lord's
they don't forget Tuesday night
set your DVRs the TBS at 7 o'clock the
guest book I suck some guys [__] you
ok I'm gonna give you the spoiler alert
right there so you know so you know
uncle Joey don't [__] around all right
I'm sucking some guys you a national TV
you know I love you I love the line I
come out with why cuz I don't give a
[__] and Greg Garcia is a [__] genius
that's why if you ain't watchin the
guest book this season you [__]
slippin he gave me two episodes but it's
not about that it's what he made me do
any episodes and the freedom that he
gave me especially dealing with these
big dog conglomerates you know I'm
saying you gotta he he is on the line of
[__] around and that's what I respect
about somebody you don't have to [__]
listen to the laws just walk around them
like a [__] Jew he seems a man I can
get a Jew attorney he just walks around
the boss and next thing you know you're
out there you could throw the Bible up
in the enemies the [__] Bible anymore
how did you attorney it I'm saying
anyway you gotta get serious
we we're gonna switch it up now to the
monster of death
there's the percentage on this check out
the percentages on this I ain't telling
you no [__] stories this [__]
bubble bubble bob-bob banana og whatever
I'm forgetting names this [__] gives you
dimension you understand me I think you
know weed is good when you get dimension
you forget your grandfather's name
grandpa who are you what the [__] anyway
I just wanted to check in with you
[__] I love you it's Sunday
it's family day this is why I don't go
on the road I want to see you
[__] I want to see my own
family they go to that other church I
can't walk in there with those fake
people
I don't like churches of this I don't
believe in [__] church going down I
got to eat a cookie you know what let me
come and go as I [__] please you got
on there for 10 minutes say hello and
get the [__] out buddy but everything
out here goes to church to see who's at
the church so they can sell you a script
it's [__] disgusting
so if I go I'd dip into 7:30 sometimes I
eat a cookie sometimes I pass you know
I'm saying I put a 20 in the box I mean
get the [__] out of there shake the
guy's hand I got a [__] to wipe it
because God knows what the guys from
what the [__] adds these people are
nasty anyway it's a beautiful [__]
day to be alive I want you to break it
down just to that it's a beautiful
[__] dare to be alive you can't get
no better than this
whatever problems you have whatever is
going on - listen snap out of this stop
it I don't care if you [__] hit
yourself in the head with a v8 snap out
of it today is a beautiful day to be
alive tomorrow who goes into the unknown
unknown all of us so who gives a [__]
about tomorrow and yesterday's gone
today you're gonna be a bad [__]
why because yong-chol Joey told you they
didn't get my might they love being a
sequin don't matter why about a ppppp
but this is the gangster wrong come on I
said it but if Emilio you're a little
eyeless I'm PC metallic gold aiyah
by acetyl I see and if you don't know
Spanish I'm not insulting you know this
America speak America Joey
it's [__] American [__] now we
talk we should be smoking and then we
got Cleveland Thursday night that's the
night you want to go down and get the
body started or who wants to go to work
so Brown Friday looking like [__] you
did twenty push-ups you want to go on
the work fry it like you stay suck your
dick they violated you got chlamydia in
your mouth you're back from meeting your
mom no big dig just get a little soil
with you [__] you want metals you
gotta have a little chlamydia at one
time anyway we gotta throw another ball
this bubblegum [__] yeah was banana ogia
[__] yeah you know why cuz that's how I
roll well that was left on the Karen
we got a smoke I am leaving nothing for
the mouse no more mouse forgets who guys
it's you and me to the [__] endless
nice and beautiful I'm Angela my stuff a
man forget about it Oh beat it there the
Cubans say anyway I love you
[__] all my heart I'm lucky you
[__] came out we got to smoke a
little dope you know I'm saying just
[__] and just talk about what we're
gonna do this week and what's important
alright now we got a little giggle and
now what's important you got take it to
the hoop this week like Julius Erving
you got to tell them all to some kid
that gets you a [__] world you got a
dream go for it and if you don't have a
dream go for it I don't give a [__] what
you want to be I don't give a [__] if
you want to sweep be the best sweeper
there is tell them all the suck your
dick understand it's your world you're
doing this thing on your terms it's like
the Niners in [__] 83 82 81 - and 81
Dallas goes into
house and giving them a point nobody
ever gives you a point because you turn
it into you're all [__] playing field
and you're always giving [__] points
you're always the [__] favorite
you follow me whether or not they got
you as the underdog you're the [__]
favorite fish anyway that's all let's
smoke another [__] ball and I'm with
you you're with me and these
[__] want to be with us why
because we don't [__] around but I ain't
got time to [__] go to Starbucks and
talk about [__] I ain't I don't know
nothing about and at the end of the day
don't [__] matter what's it got to do
with the [__] price tags you know
what to do with the prices you get up
and being a [__] soldier you
understand me oh they got one more I got
I got things to do people to see you
gotta clean up
I gotta make a little [__] harlot
protein shake nice today nice I weighed
myself this morning at 9 o'clock over
and wave watches I didn't stay for the
meeting of the place is packed and I had
a fart take a [__] you know you don't
wanna be sitting amongst a bunch of fat
people now they're looking at all each
other you're farting room for five
people you cause the [__] controversy
anyway Cleveland Thursday Friday
Saturday my [__] homey George Perez
Tuesday night set your DVRs do me a
personal favor
set your DVR guestbook watch me soup I
mean and that's it that's that next
people talking about Netflix and
whatever else is going on the [__]
the tour and everything else but as far
as time is concerned I want you to go
out there and spread love but don't let
nobody [__] with you let him know the
Yearwood uncle Joey I'm with you you're
with me and they could all suck my dick
and call it shorty I'm saying Joey
what's with that weed and the binding
finish it [__] it and the savage loves
you
anyway I love you [__] have a
great week you have a podcast tomorrow
I had [__] 6 a.m. ready to go and
then another one on Wednesday morning
and I'll see you [__] in
Cleveland on Thursday night oh yeah I
love you [__] stay black
I got you